[Music]
so have there been discussions for you
to be the bachelor I have heard
rumblings about it but you know what
it's something that through this
experience it is exceeded my
expectations in every single way shape
so you would do it so I would be willing
to do it have you talked to producers
about I can't discuss that and I don't
know I think there's a laundry list of
people who would be willing to this is
the topic come up in conversation you
missed out on the bachelor in paradise
trauma why didn't you go to paradise
so for me the turnaround was too quick
it was a tough breakup it was emotional
and I just wasn't in the headspace for
that and don't think it was a good fit
for me then and we'll see if it is down
the road I came into this rooting for
your happiness I always leave Jason
seems like a great candidate for
bachelor there's several though what do
you think the next buffalo what do you
think so is it Jason for you no I mean
look here's the thing we always had the
flavor of the month you know I mean you
know how it goes with the public
perception and the excitement he's gonna
come out of this and be a favorite we've
been through this and this isn't my
first rodeo and so what we will do is we
will weather this storm and he's
definitely a candidate cuz he's a great
guy and obviously can converse and
articulate very well unlike Joe and and
so no obviously he's in the mix he's a
great guy but we want you to watch
paradise I want you know we got a we got
a lot more homework to do before we get
to that decision
[Music]